[Musique]
je me présente bac heurte à 24 ans
rappeur il y monte un
un artiste
qui m'a beaucoup inspiré c'est pas le
seul dans ma jeunesse mais
c'est l'un des artistes qui m'a qui m'a
inspiré et du coup on novembre 2018
j'avais sorti un morceau en son nom qui
avait plutôt bien marché qui avait été
validée par le parquet et james qui mêle
jeu parfois je crois percevoir madame
espoirs drapeau blanc main mais ce n'est
qu'un mirage car aussi bizarre que cela
puisse sembler lac est rempli plus de
bouche remplie plus de poche et porte
monnaie que son ennemi la paix
je vais interpréter
trois chansons de mon projet cette cave
8 une chanson que j'ai fait quand
j'étais plus jeune
donc il y aura bien évidemment aussi le
parmi des trois y aura le morceau kery
james
et je vais faire omar c'est aussi le
conte à la trappe
même si des france mon départ face
pour fonder tous nos soucis noblet nobel
du coup j'enchaîne donc demain soir je
fais mon premier concert officiel donc
j'ai fait beaucoup de scène j'ai fait
des tremplins des fêtes de la musique
j'ai fait pas mal d'événements mais
demain soir c'est mon concert c'est
voilà ma billetterie ce qui est sûr
c'est que après ce week-end ouais je
pense qu'
une page va se fermer pour en ouvrir une
autre bien sûr mais c'est vraiment une
consécration